all right let's get into the Friday Feed
Bag AKA Friday feedback you can email
info davidpackman.com sometimes we will
highlight for your uh viewing and
listening pleasure or displeasure a
Facebook message that we receive or a
YouTube comment that we spot or could
really come from anywhere uh yeah let's
just get right into it first message
today came from Cheryl via Facebook
Cheryl says hi your sir are an idiot
when told by our auto reply that I'm
unable to reply to every message
individually
Cheryl added yes tell him to get his
facts right we here in Florida love our
governor and the job he's doing
so pull your head out of your ass and
get someone else besides Ruth left wing
nut to rebutt her I don't have the
slightest idea what Cheryl is talking
about and interestingly we get a ton of
messages like this and it really is
unclear to me like I know that it's not
that these folks aren't native English
speakers I know that that's not the case
sometimes out of morbid curiosity we
will look and it'll be like oh no Cheryl
was born in you know Jupiter Florida or
something like that
um and is uh is a native English speaker
so are these
typing problems are these voice to text
issues why is it that the emails and
messages I get from right Wingers are so
overwhelmingly disastrous when it comes
to
syntax and format and everything I don't
know I don't know
um Vivian calexillos says I dare David
Pacman to have an intellectual
conversation live stream with Russell
Brand and see how he holds up maybe a
little humbling would do him some good
but only big brave people rise up to a
challenge like this so it won't happen
I want to explain to Vivian and others a
little something okay
um I get emails all the time saying well
if you think Russell Brand is so wrong
about stuff have them on your show if
you think Ben Shapiro is wrong have him
on your show you won't because you're
scared we invite all of these people it
is they who don't want to be on now in
their defense maybe my show is two small
potatoes or small bananas for them fine
but it is not because I'm scared that
they aren't on this show it's because
they don't respond to our requests to be
on Russell Brand is welcome anytime
and Vivian it's not because of me that
he's not here it's because he doesn't
want to do it which is his right I don't
think I have a right to debate Russell
Brand the way some of these
right-wingers say but Russell's welcome
anytime
uh the anti-trans rhetoric is very
strong among the right-wing elements of
our audience right now Christopher uh
put on YouTube quote I mean so talking
about my daughter I guess I mean if you
want your daughter to have to use the
same bathroom as a six foot three
bearded muscular man more power to you
the rest of us will make sure to protect
our daughters wives mothers and other
biological women in our lives
you know when I see something like this
I really wonder
is Christopher really a dad like where
my mind really goes to is to that
because I have to tell you I know so
many people who have daughters myself
included
and the trans bathroom issue quite
literally never enters my mind now I
understand right now my daughter's two
feet tall she can't even walk so the
idea that she's going to end up in a
bathroom by herself or whatever like I
get that it's not an issue but even when
I think about the next five years the
next 10 years and the things that you
know going to school and travel and camp
and all these different things the trans
bathroom issue doesn't even enter my
mind as an issue so it makes me question
like what's going on in Christopher's
life
that this is really what he's thinking
about or is it all made up does
Christopher not really have uh a
daughter Cuba
um on uh I guess CRT Marxism trans stuff
Cuba says he was right it's taught my
daughter is in Middle School in
California and I've seen her homework
assignments when I was in high school I
had quite a few Marxist teachers this is
America we believe in capitalism and
free market if you don't like it move to
Cuba ask any Cuban American why their
family left and they'll tell you the
horrors of socialism listen I'm the
wrong guy to make this argument too
um I have never been a defender of the
Castro regime I wanted normalization of
relations with Cuba because the Embargo
was hypocritical it was a double
standard and I try to avoid absurd
double standards but I that was for the
benefit of the Cuban people it was not
because I am a defender of the Castro
regime so I am very well aware that
there is this overreaction among many
Cuban Americans Cuban Americans are one
of the few
um groups of uh of Hispanic Americans
that regularly vote for republicans and
part of it is because of their
um aversion to uh Cuba and the Castro
regime they see even like food stamps as
Socialism or Marxism which of course
it's not
um so I I'm the wrong guy to do the go
back to Cuba thing too by the way I've
never been to Cuba anyway but I would be
interested in visiting user one who
sleeps not posted on Reddit and this is
an interesting topic is David putting
too much emphasis on Ron desantis's lack
of charisma Pacman is frequently
referred to DeSantis as abysmal lack of
Charisma and pointed out that he
certainly doesn't seem to have the same
energy Trump had in 2016. seems true
enough but I wonder if it really matters
art depicting of trump often Slims him
down to a ridiculous degree his stream
of Consciousness bellyaching at rallies
has been hailed as some of the greatest
speeches of all times by his followers
his extensive and obvious political
failures have been recast as
Machiavellian 4D chess moves to trip up
and ensnare his enemies Evangelical
preachers have praised this lecture and
Thief as a true man of God or the tool
by which God will restore the country to
Greatness I don't think desantis's lack
of Charisma will matter one bit people
see what they want to see and I don't
doubt their memes and leaders will help
them see DeSantis in an implausibly good
light
I don't think so
and here's why the reason that
everything Trump does is seen as a great
thing by Trump's followers is that many
of Trump's followers are people who
never followed the political system and
many of them never even voted until
Trump arrived on the political scene
they are a different sort of voter and
the DeSantis voter as I currently
understand the DeSantis voter to be is
someone who is more engaged with
politics and is a little more connected
to reality than the average Trump voter
and wants something different than Trump
so my opinion right now and this could
change is that the average DeSantis
supporter or potential DeSantis
supporter
would be much more influenced by the
reality of DeSantis and would be less
willing to recast every aspect of
DeSantis as a positive trait the way
that Trump supporters are because
fundamentally Trump supporters and
non-maga Republicans are very different
groups I want to hear from you on that
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe my perspective is
wrong Demon King commented on YouTube as
a trans woman I just don't feel safe
anymore living in a less than
Progressive state is taxing it's a shame
that I have to carry defense items just
to feel safe
thank you David for always reporting the
truth as you always do they will not
stop until they have something else to
grift to history is unkind to anyone who
chooses to try to suppress anyone's
rights well you know I am reminded
of Arnold Schwarzenegger's recent
12-minute video that he did last week
or the week before and he says in it
the people who try to deny others rights
they end up being losers in history and
he talks about his own Nazi sympathizing
father this is Arnold Schwarzenegger
check out the video If you haven't seen
it and so I do maintain hope and quite
frankly I do think it's likely that the
anti-trans people will end up losers I
mean listen the anti-gay people have
basically ended up losers gay marriage
is now legal nationally it's more
acceptable culturally than at any point
in American history of the modern
political era so the anti-gay people are
increasingly losers they're both losers
legislatively and they're just losers
when you you know at this point it is
far more common that if someone just
casually uses the f word to refer to gay
people
most of the people around them are going
to look at them like what that dude what
are you talking about why using that
word so the anti-gay people are
increasingly losers
My Hope Is that Arnold is correct and
that the anti-trans people also will end
up being losers and history will be
unkind to them but the concern is in the
short term they can really make a lot of
people's lives very miserable and that
is what I want to prevent but very uh
good and sad comment there William
commented about my practice of removing
the free Bibles left in hotel rooms from
hotel rooms when I travel Williams said
David I understand you have a right to
remove a Bible from your hotel room but
I'm curious why if it's in a draw I
think he means drawer if it's in a
drawer out of sight how is it offensive
well I never said it was offensive I
understand you are of Jewish faith are
you not allowed by your faith to have
the Bible in your personal space it is
not a question of what Judaism allows me
to do I'm not even a religious person
here's the way I see it
when I
rent a hotel room or you know Reserve
stay in a hotel room
I am looking to stay in a room that
provides me a comfortable bed
maybe free coffee
a TV Wi-Fi a clean and comfortable
bathroom
a quiet room far from the elevator so I
can get a good night's sleep you know
whatever
I am not looking for nor do I consider
it something that is appropriate to
provide me a hotel room that is all
those things plus it provides Christian
reading materials first of all why why
Christian reading materials but why not
some other it doesn't make any sense I'm
not looking for a hotel room that is all
of the things I mentioned and gives me
Christian reading material
so what I do I'm not mad at anybody
I'm not looking to have anybody arrested
I'm not looking to have anybody insulted
is I just put that free Bible left by
The Gideons out in the hallway or in the
recycling bin I'm not offended it's not
that I'm not allowed it's just I'm not
looking to stay in rooms that have been
pre-populated with the allegedly sacred
texts of one of a thousand religions
it's just not what I'm looking for so I
just do my quiet thing and I go okay
I'll just take that out the towels I
want the free soaps I'm looking for a
nice conditioner to try to get my hair
under control great but the Bible is
just not part of what I'm looking for in
a hotel room so if I happen to see it I
don't go looking for it if I happen to
see it
I just put it out in the hallway like a
room service tray a couple people wrote
to me and were offended many people
wrote to me and said they do the same
thing one person canceled their paid
subscription I'm not gonna hide from you
that that's something I do if I remember
and I'll be honest many times I stay in
a hotel one night for some work thing I
don't even come across the Bible I don't
even check it was probably there it's no
big deal
it's just not a big deal everybody
remain calm please we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com replace the guy who
canceled his membership because I put
the Bible in the hallway and you can use
the coupon code 24 starts now to get
yourself a discount